wildfires swept through here and left a
haunting site
the flames are gone but look at the
smoldering soil
i'm firefighter still 26 years and i
never knew that situation
fire chief stephanie mata says drought
and heatwave are a deadly combination
when it's dry weather
all the water in the vegetables are just
going
out when the fire arrives
it's just um
easier
because
all the trees have less defense
to
fight against the fire
the wildfires in gerond have been
burning for weeks
they're battling around the clock on the
ground and from the air
there are 1500 firefighters here from
all over europe
and closer to home we found village
vigilantes local volunteers carrying and
doing what they can
[Music]
but they all agree they won't give up
it feels relentless
this is the problem walk anywhere in the
forest and you'll find these pockets of
smoke the peat soil here is now so hot
you can actually feel the heat rising up
from the ground below
it is truly terrifying for people here
they desperately need rain but can only
hope it comes soon